[Music]
according to israel's central elections
committee
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has a
path
to forming the fifth government in two
years
but it'll be a difficult one it appears
the netanyahu block
is poised to secure 59 seats of a
required
61 in the knesset there's no reason why
we should go to a fifth election
and they must come to netanyahu and say
we want to be part of the government we
accept the results of this
round and form a right of center
government
that could aggressively pursue the
opportunities we have ahead of us
the religious zionist party and alliance
of the far right
fared better than anticipated and is
expected to bring its projected
six seats to a netanyahu government
members of the party have been banned in
the past
for anti-palestinian sentiment
the palestinian-israeli parties are
projected to lose seats
this round voter turnout was low the
parties previously voted as one block
under the arab joint list but the group
splintered
and a second conservative party called
the united arab list
formed now its leader mansour abbas
could potentially do something
unheard of previously support
netanyahu's government
likud party members remain divided on
what would be
a historic alliance
critics such as opposition leader yair
lapid of the yeshateed party
say netanyahu's drive to remain in power
is centered
on finding a way to evade prosecution on
corruption charges
and they argue forging ties with the
religious zionist party
would create a racist ultra-conservative
government
but in this election netanyahu must
attempt to forge a coalition
with diverse smaller parties given the
narrow divide between the pro and
anti-netanyahu camps that means
these smaller parties and their leaders
find themselves
with a huge influence in determining
israel's
political path forward natasha ghanim al
jazeera
west jerusalem
right more with harry fawcett in west
jerusalem now hi harry just when you
think it's all going to be predictable
just as it was again
this happens take us through the process
from now and i mean is there a time
frame on what we can expect
well yes the israeli president has
a certain period during which to assess
who is the most likely
of the contenders to be able to form a
coalition government that is usually the
leader
of the party the single party that has
got got the most votes in the election
so
that is likely to be benjamin netanyahu
and then he would have
in the first instance four weeks from
that point
to try to put together such a coalition
but this
development uh which looked uh
not to have happened when the exit polls
and even hours later after the exit
polls came out
or late on tuesday night with
the united arab list having not
apparently made it past a 3.25 percent
share of the vote required even to get
in
to the parliament now that they have
done it has really
uh set everything uh on its head because
now netanyahu's block is
under the margin so is the potential
opposition
there are those in liukud who are
talking about potentially working with
mansoor abbas the leader of this party
who has
tried to position uh the party since
deciding to break away from the rest
of the joint list as uh somewhere in the
middle between those those two rival
camps between sort of the mainstream and
even right-wing
zionist parties and the the
palestinian-israeli
arab parties he says he's doing so for
pragmatic reasons to try to
get policy on the ground in favor of his
constituents
and that to do such a thing he would
consider working
with either the right or the left camp
he doesn't want a label
but if he worked with netanyahu and
there are two ways he could do that
either
unprecedentedly entering a coalition
with the liquid and its other right wing
allies
or by promising not to vote against a
minority government
uh made up of those constituent parts if
that happened he would find himself
working on the same side
as this extreme right-wing grouping the
religious zionist movement which
contains
descendants of a party that was deemed
so anti-arab racist
in the 1990s that it was banned from the
knesset all together so huge
contradictions there
but also on the other side too there is
a broad ideological spectrum
of anti-netanyahu parties some of whom
are themselves
very right-wing even further right-wing
than netanyahu who also say they would
not work with what they see as a
conservative islamist
party such as that led by mansour abbas
so it's extraordinarily
complicated the gears are grinding once
again
in this long-running political crisis
and
still no obvious resolution at hand
fascinating isn't it
so interesting thank you harry fawcett
in west jerusalem
a little more now on what it takes and
what's in play to form the government in
israel it's the knesset it's a 120
member legislator
just so the magic number to come to
power the ones in blue 61 of them now
projections show that that number
all of those blue ones would elude
netanyahu and his likud party
also likely not possible for the
coalition of parties which oppose them
and as we were just hearing from harry
that small palestinian israeli party
which the pulses say could win as many
as five seats
could be holding uh the balance of power
israel's electoral system it's a complex
form of proportional representation
which
as we've seen makes it quite difficult
for any single party to win
an election outright more with our
senior political analyst now
marwan bashara marwan i don't even think
we mentioned the name
in mansur yesterday uh when we were
going through
all the possibilities and what could
happen suddenly
he sees himself in the spotlight and as
harry was saying possibly not just with
likud but with the far
right party even for israeli politics
this is pretty extraordinary
it is uh extraordinary that's why i
don't think it's realistic
um you know theoretically anything can
happen
theoretically there is no difference
between theoretically and practically
in practice there is so
i don't think in real life we're going
to see
uh naftali bennett of yamina party
the extreme right-wing party sit with
abbas in the same coalition
certainly won't say the zionist
religious party
the most extreme of most extreme
fundamentalist
jewish parties sitting together in the
same coalition
as an islamist party i don't see it
at all what i will see is in the next
month
or 45 days that there will be a lot of
maneuvering and netanyahu will use abbas
and abbas will use netanyahu in order
for both of them
to try to entice other parties to join
but those with a bit of a memory
kamal will remember how netanyahu
in the mid 90s incited against
then prime minister itzhak rabin
for daring to depend
on a palestinian party
in the knesset in order to pass
a a resolution uh within parliament
so much so that that incitement was
whipped up
so feverishly that it led to the
assassination
of yitzhak rabin in 1995. that was
netanyahu and that
is still netanyahu netanyahu that
incited to the killing of
one israeli prime minister because he
depended
on and on an arab party will not
depend on an arab party himself
it's 2021 though now marwan and i
i feel i wonder is netanyahu more
desperate now to hold on to power given
everything he's gone through given he's
been the prime minister for so long the
corruption charges and all these things
never know what he might do
this is what's so both fascinating and
disturbing
about this whole episode because we are
now faced with a situation that
basically the one person who can
theoretically form a government
would be netanyahu and i think he would
be doing it by peeling off
some of the members of the of the of the
mid-sized parties
offering them ministerial positions or
even mid-sized parties themselves like
blue white party or whoever
and and offering them really enticing
offers in order for them to join the
government
and even that is a bit far-fetched
because he
doesn't only want him to join the
government is to change
the judiciary both in order to please
the religious parties and in order for
him not to go on trial so i think that
would be his path
however and i think this is probably the
thing that we have not discussed yet
that while he could be the deal maker
that he
is the deal maker he is also the biggest
obstacle for the formation
of a liquid-led coalition
government if netanyahu
leaves the scene or nudged off
the helm of the liquid party somehow
likud then could form a coalition
government by a good number
of mid-sized parties in israel
including its nemesis yashatid including
blue and white party including the new
whole party
including yamina party and so on so
forth
so likud has potential to form a
government it wouldn't be great for
israel
it won't be great for the palestinians
it won't be great for peace
but it is possible if netanyahu leaves
the scene
wow it's going to be interesting isn't
it thank you marwan bashara is our
senior political analyst
thank you